le week-end de pâques et comme chaque
année une période de forte affluence
dans les parcs de loisirs en région
parisienne deux concepts s'oppose le
parc astérix face à eurodisney le
village gaulois tir cette fois moins de
visiteurs que le géant américain mais
compense par une gestion maîtrisée et
des attractions à taille humaine nicolas
lemarignier jacques gérard une
inauguration digne d'hollywood
disneyland paris n'a pas lésiné pour le
lancement de sa nouvelle attraction
tirée du film toy story 2 un tunnel des
cibles mouvantes que l'on vise à coups
de pistolet de l'espace ce sont les
ingrédients pour séduire les enfants et
leurs parents
il ya des choses qui vont plaire aux
petits comme des couleurs très vif des
disciples est très facile puis il ya des
choses aussi par exemple qui vont plaire
aux grands dégâts qu un peu adulte et
cachets chaque année le parc de
marne-la-vallée accueille plus de 12
millions de visiteurs les attractions
s'adresse à toute la famille mais sont
avant tout destinés aux enfants et aux
grands enfants
j'aime bien l'autre j'aime bien les
pirates et kari kari
des petites sommes pour les camps de
fournir à quelques kilomètres de là le
parc astérix les gaulois attire cette
fois moins de visiteurs que leurs
voisins grande différence ici les
adultes ont d attraction rien que pour
eux
et puis on met en avant les spectacles
et l'interactivité
la différence chez nous c'est qu'on est
- contemplatif complète chez disney
quand on est plus actif que l'on
participe aux activités que l'on a des
émotions qu'on partage en famille fort
comme garçons cette année les vikings
débarque au parc pour un spectacle au
milieu du public alors mickey ou astérix
grandes oreilles ou gros nez
les gaulois résiste plutôt bien un côté
du géant américain
il arrive même à être plus rentable tous
leurs voisins de l'ain